and today we are going to be guessing
some serving sizes of some slices I said
[Music]
nice and I refused to do it again hi I'm
Connie
I'm Andrew hi I see I'm 2 1 and today
we're guessing the serving sizes of
snacks it's night time we out here get
snacks
it's next I eat a lot of junk food
especially here at the office it's
become a really bad habit wait and
that's literally my also same how dare
they give us free snacks we're pretty
big on snacks we actually our desk mates
yeah we've shared a snack or two in our
day I log most of what I eat so like I
do use like a weighing scale and stuff
to kind of like try and figure out what
the serving sizes are I personally pride
myself at licking at the back of
packaging you know like I like to see
the ingredients it doesn't stop me from
eating it I just like to tell people
that I do it
ok so first up we have the Lay's potato
chips how do you feel about Lay's potato
chips I feel like they're the poor man's
potato chip you got nothing else but you
need a potato chip that lays is always
there for you
what's the rich man's potato chip
ruffled see how much didn't this lookin
like a normal snack size like 28 to 21
they say 28 chips okay sometimes is one
serving size now comes the math portion
my least favorite portion okay
I like to look at the weight cuz then
when you count you could have a bigger
chip or you could not smile that's where
this gets tricky okay how many Ounces
are in a cup if two bags of chips go
into a train and one leaves the our head
which which serving size I'm gonna guess
like 23 I think it's fine too
yeah like tweeting this might a little
more but like yeah
and boom oh it's perfect and you don't
even have to count it oh yeah not bad we
splitted that was good so we weren't bad
we sell like 23 ok banana me know how to
like for whatever comes up next we can
kind of figure it out from there
15 I feel like that's not enough I need
a good 25 15 I feel like no I used to I
think that's one where I realize yeah I
should probably stop eating 10 a day
it's probably not good ok I already feel
like this is entrapment though because
these come too - a package right it's
already figured out for you woo they
give me - I eat - what am I supposed to
do like save the other one I'm vlogging
this before but not a serving is usually
one of the pop-tart ok so I feel like
it's one I love pop-tarts probably not a
great breakfast food but for me like
where the breakfast foods growing up and
I'm not kidding you my pop-tart serving
was for for per meal
5 grams of fat 38 carbs 2 grams of
protein that sounds like one pop-tart to
me I think it's a safe bet yeah yeah I
think that I think they're wanting us to
say - I'm leaning toward Wanda I feel
good about that
all right that's one pop-tart that's one
hot dog cuz it's like you pop it and you
share it so I think that's why it's - -
about these are our perfect death treat
those are there's one for you one for me
anyway more pop-tarts we need to talk
about hold on we have a desk meeting so
we need to edit one time
guess who's back but they're trying to
do is make it seem to matter a lot of
this but you eat the two and you think
you just got what I always the - yeah
right I never night - all right you're
gonna have to leave the team on this one
these are the flamin hot crunchy Cheetos
and I don't even like Cheetos oh there
it is
the cause of all my pain and misery also
love love it's a love-hate relationship
it's complicated
no I'm not a huge spicy food person you
know I like it that I'm gonna say 13:13
I'll say like 15 16 a little bit higher
a little higher
I'm being ambitious you know being
consumed changing it up going back to
the lace because they gave us a number
yeah and this one's a little bit bigger
so it was eight and a half I suppose
eight before 22 at 22 and half 22 and a
half is our final number we feel great
about it
some of us feel great about it I'm sorry
I have to be tilled those - okay ready
ready yeah okay all right oh wait wait
this is debatable wait
this is you can't even tell which one is
which this is debatable
oh you're right he said 16 yeah let it
be known that he's a it's like it's like
a curve your degree yeah we're two and
one right now
that's like far I would just save 3 4 3
3 4 3 I was gonna say I don't like
double stuff that's too much cream it's
too much cream in the Oreo I definitely
like a sleeve never I buy from the
grocery store I open it up have some and
the whole row was gone I'm like I hate
myself
take this is a formal request to switch
seats in the office this is broken our
friendship it's broken our lives
I'm gonna guess - because they're so bad
it's I wish it wasn't I wish it was like
soon this is what I would like to do
with the serving size Amelia I think of
a 3 still too much I know right yeah
more feels good right
Flor feels good cuz - is too little 7
we're the rest of the or you forgot some
Oreos under here excuse me producer I'm
sorry I'm happy to know that we were
right not to know that we can't eat more
who ease into it in time or is it even
in my life it's not good this one I
think I'm passing you the bar because
the only thing I like about goldfish is
the theme song I feel like the serving
is 55 because there's yeah I might be
crazy but because they're smaller yeah
another makes sense I'm six point six
ounces okay so that's less than the last
two what does 50 look like so I'm trying
to picture how it looks like in here
five my gut is telling me like twelve or
something like that
yeah let's round up - yeah let's do like
twelve I forgot about twelve this is a
little bit too much okay let's go down
my name is 40 Oh 40 yeah that works for
me here's like a handful I I need to at
least eat a handful
no no I think that's good okay I think
that's good 20 feels right 20 I like how
you took control of that I feel good
about it and if I can't have a whole
handful of goldfish what society do we
live in even America anymore if you can
fish you feel like that's good yeah
before we commit okay that's 55 okay so
we were right about 55 okay oh we're and
Irbid no 55 oh this is green news oh
don't worry Oh debacle we needed this
one it looked a lot smaller than I
thought yeah well I'm glad to know that
our number was right and like we said
our number was lost so 55 was correct we
just eyeballed it wrong so M&Ms we want
to talk about a dick tip like all of a
sudden you're eating these and then you
look down the bags gone just I don't
know where where it goes I don't know
how it happened it could be in the movie
theatre it could be with your friends it
could be at home I don't know they're
really small very similar to goldfish
and it just of course your very very
different snacks but I don't know I feel
like they would be around to see them
out okay okay no chocolate I usually go
peanut me to know what this mates are
bad you know I don't really eat I mean
I'm like by themselves all the time I
feel like they're just kind of like if
if they happen to be around yeah you
know one big well I'll just take some
any they're exactly a little fun size
pack yeah that's fine yeah how does that
feel I don't even know how many but like
let's just this look it's eyeball it a
little bit I think we'd go a little bit
more 25 25 yeah 23 to 25 and 5 I feel
like that's right
okay favourite M&M color the brown one
that the brown ones were the only
chocolate ones so I would only eat the
chocolate ones out of the bag and then
my sister is filling this video and
dying laughing right now was like no
Connie
they all had chocolate and she like
forced me to eat like a red one and then
then I thought I said then I gave in a
little and I said okay so the brown ones
and I can't prove it so you thought it
was like a starburst or something like I
thought the rest was like here's the
lime and then yeah cause there's a whole
lot that looks like 40 it was so high
last time yeah you gotta go in the 30s
at least 30 yes I think that I don't
think that's 30 no we'll see I don't
know I all I know is goldfish fooled us
and 20 carbs isn't a lot of
okay 45 is our bet 45 is our bet we
didn't really count them but just
imagine that we said 45 let me counted
them all okay okay that looks like the
same 32 I'm sorry I screwed you again
what I'm even doing here
no this is my last video I can't be
betrayed like this again I mean who are
serving sizes 4 isn't it for like that
was for the most part I would say we got
most of them by flick gold which was the
one that hadn't really threw us off I
think everything we saw today seems
pretty reasonable I'm not gonna stop
anything more than this stuff which win
surprised you the most the Oreo hurt the
most the Oreo hurt the most
but goldfish I felt like I mean you go
to stuff like 55 is enough to satisfy my
snack cranium I felt good about it
oh good about 55 goldfish you got it
going on even if we got the pieces wrong
if you look at it it looks pretty
correct like you said goldfish is really
the only one that threw us for a loop
there and I feel like a lot of is when
you weigh it it's not necessarily what's
counted out I will definitely think
about it for sure whenever I'm like
snacking here in the future it's
something that I actually will like
contemplate now knowing the number now
that I want to this is a hell that you
put me in thank you so much for this
video I feel better after it thank you
for ruining snacks forever
[Music]